[Music]
oh come on squid game did you have to
start off the next episode by reminding
us that 199 is gone it was traumatic
enough when it happened the first time i
spent so much time already processing
through it in the 4.8 seconds you gave
me before you fired up the next episode
dumb watches make sure you catch up the
vips will arrive soon show momentarily
acts like the urgency of this matter is
predicated on the arrival of a bunch of
jerks that want bottle service but
follows up with no one frontman included
doing anything differently than they
were before so in the end this was just
an fyi to the viewer you're looking at
me like you've seen a ghost are you okay
oh my what a plot twist did the writers
really expect us to believe a main
character is going to be randomly killed
off screen of course not it'd only be
shocking if they did i'm giving the show
a sin for teasing such a bizarre exit
for this character and not following
through with it and yes if they'd
followed through with it i'd give it a
sin for just being bizarre welcome to tv
sins hope you enjoy your stay hey this
guy knows about it the weakest link
trying to defend your favorite game show
by finding one other person who's heard
of it before are you in here right now
looks like today's not squid game will
be hide and seek at least that's what i
assume considering the front man is
essentially doing a long-winded version
of ready or not here i come instead of
you know just looking for the intruder
without giving up the clear advantage
known as the element of surprise you
made one mistake
i always put the receiver down the other
way running the receiver cord across the
phone you monster also even if it's
intentional i love how the aha got you
measure you put in place is phone
receiver orientation as opposed to
things like security cameras motion
detectors or actual functioning human
guards what's a cop doing here without a
partner how do you know he doesn't have
a partner just because you know he shot
that bullet and someone fell for your
super high-tech phone receiver setup
doesn't mean there couldn't be another
person with him i'm sure you have lots
of questions it's not too late to come
out and talk i can't imagine juho has
many other questions in this moment
aside from why are you trying to have a
conversation with me that being said the
come out and let's have a talk line
frequently used by villains would make a
more compelling scene if people
occasionally took them up on the offer
they actually had a chat and reconciled
their differences but this doesn't
happen it never does stop putting this
in your stories leaving the store and
every other door in this area unlocked
we found a body this call alone coming
in just in time to prevent this showdown
is sinfully convenient but on top of
that a moment ago the front man was so
convinced someone was in here he was
talking to them and all it took to
derail this partially completed search
was a call about finding a singular body
on an island dedicated to murder gaming
or there also happened to be an
unsanctioned organ harvesting scheme
going on in tandem what i'm saying is
their body's literally everywhere but he
assumes they found the droid he's
looking for just because the plot needs
him to also he never says hello or
anything when he picks up the guy on the
other end just starts talking anyway
whether or not walkie-talkies have
evolved to silently notify you when
someone answers this is just bad two-way
radio etiquette over i know i've
mentioned it before but even with more
of the beds missing and this much of
these stick game squid figures showing
not a single person has mentioned the
possibility of maybe looking at the wall
to see which game might be next
making out with your potato also
competing in a winner-take-all death
game with your friend and or spouse
undeniably makes you an [ __ ] so i can
understand after the last game while the
production team chose potatoes for the
scene there's no reason to guild the
apple blossom but doksu aggressively
eats this egalitarian root fruit to
emphasize that he is the king [ __ ]
and deserves a sin as well and yes i
know that fruit is spelled wrong and
then potato is not a fruit and then i'm
the real king [ __ ]
yummy this is what it looks like when
crabs have been placed on a body by a
set designer in real life they're much
more likely to swim alongside you while
encouraging you to suck face with anyone
who may be accompanying you
[Music]
if a body comes along you must scan it
we found this police id on him which
brings the question why did he put his
id on the guard he killed i mean sure he
probably didn't want to be carrying
around with him in case he was caught
but what's the plus side to having it
found on the corpse just check that
thing off separately you want to start
from the beginning again false
dichotomies
holy sh did you hear the sound that mask
made when you put it down
not even sure how to approach the
science on this one mostly because i
slept through my material science class
twice and then changed majors but
there's no way anyone would be wearing
this thing for any amount of time i mean
i love the flare but they have to be so
impractically heavy that the only
possible reason these fanciful furry
fetishists could wear these things for
the entire episode is that this sound
was the result of bad communication with
the foley artist
americans oh lord be my shepherd be my
guy this prays on for some time trust me
the screens we have at home are plenty
big but
nothing beats seeing it with your own
eyes oh this is just like in the nba
playoffs where they don't sell the
in-person tickets for the first few
rounds what's that they do sell tickets
to every single nba game weird bringing
in the vips after half the experience is
already over just makes so much sense oh
it's uh such a beautiful number
69 oh you're dirty
you can think that when the english
speakers came in that maybe the painful
voice acting of the dubbed version would
subside for a bit as we listen to
characters speak with their own voices
you'd think so but you'd be wrong so
very wrong the fact that these colored
platforms for the vips aren't all
circles squares or triangles is an
absolute travesty of consistent design
you made the buttons on the security
camera controls these shapes but for
this you go with what a cloud shape a
cloud
god dammit just tell us about the next
game
how long you're gonna string us along
like this half leopard mask [ __ ]
would be excellent at squid game sins
he's in a bad mood because of 69. well
that's just counterintuitive
looks like a bridge of some sort aside
from revealing that the people behind
the murder olympics are just a bunch of
rich dicks nearly all of the vip
dialogue is just filler to convey their
vague interest in the whole production i
wish the show would just give all these
guys some gold-plated apples and move on
to the bridge to squidobithia game
already please make your way down the
steps and choose one of the mannequins
that you see presented before you once
you've chosen take the corresponding
vest i'm skeptical about whether the
process of choosing the order is
actually all that fair but i'm more
annoyed that they're making the already
numbered individuals choose another
number so the sin is excessive numbering
there are plenty of other variables but
i think the order in which they compete
matters most does position well if i
can't do 69
i'll try 96. ah yes the lesser-known
sexual position where partners lay
back-to-back with their butts resting on
the back of each other's necks also
known as the cheeky reeky it's really
popular in certain parts of the florida
panhandle from what i understand there's
16 people left
and there are 16 numbers once again our
hero coming through with the razor sharp
observations the amount of people in
this episode stating obvious things for
our benefit is astonishing i can't tell
if the show has all of a sudden become
stupid or just thinks we are but either
way here's your sin not performing the
cheeky reiki correctly they always take
the middle numbers first less than five
minutes ago you saw this setup and had
no clue what this game was but now
you're familiar enough with it to know
what the players always do
okay do it i can't confirm this due to
the fact that they're all wearing animal
masks and that the line was said
off-screen but i'm nearly 100 sure that
was bojack horseman and now i'm upset he
didn't get a bigger role in the show
somehow as always i'm choosing my number
last second to last 96 if you were
choosing your number last there'd be no
choice in fact no one chooses their
number last they take their number last
really the person who chooses last is
the one before the final note
i've talked so long i've disproved
myself again haven't i these vests
shouldn't be the same color as the
guard's outfits phew saved it this whole
number selection process accounts for
six minutes of this episode's run time
that's around ten percent i don't even
give my manager 10 percent and this
scene is definitely doing less work than
carl oh wow it's bigger title of doctor
who's sex tape also did they think the
contestants were going to play on that
model bridge what is this a squid game
for ants the fifth game is glass
stepping stones all right glass stepping
stones classic children's playground
game good call the tempered glass
stepping stones are strong enough to
hold the weight of two people
however the normal glass will break even
if just one person steps on it don't
worry about the fact that you're all
different weights and that there might
be two smaller people who weigh about
the same as one bigger person the glass
has read the script and knows what to do
have you ever kicked your feet up on a
naked human leopard footstool while
sitting up and forward like this put
strain on your hamstrings and abs the
only reason he's got his leg up there
right now is because the set designer
was like we spent five hours in makeup
on this body pain by golly you're gonna
use it mister
[Music]
pain relief that's it
keep
doing that one after the other yes keep
getting lucky just try really hard i saw
a poster once that said luck is what
happens when preparation meets
opportunity so now's your chance also i
think he's well aware he should keep
picking the right one this is like when
someone tells you to drive safe thanks
aunt susan guess the blindfold kane and
ferret idea i had will have to wait for
another day 2 to the power 15.
what time's
one in 32 768.
[Music]
i'm surprised no one's intended to make
a run for it oh never mind well at least
i'm going to send the fact that no one
attempts to walk along the red rail sure
it's probably against some rule no one
knows or that they haven't made up yet
and anyone who attempted this would end
up being shot down by a drone carrying
crossbows or some but if any of that's
true we deserve to see it the series
shows us all the deadly details we don't
want for six episodes but now that we've
acclimated to this blood sport they let
up you happen to remember what he chose
next even if she doesn't certainly one
of the other 12 would have been paying
close attention you know what with
everyone's lives on the line and all
right benefits every single person here
for each contestant to get as far as
possible so i'm befuddled as to why this
isn't a more cooperative group
conversation if one of those players
gets scared and starts to run down the
time
we're in danger in the back of the line
true so my question is what happens if
they all die does everyone just go home
do the vips get their money back this is
shoddy game planning at best
there's that sweet sweet squid game
visual flair i know and love take a sin
off for this gorgeous tracking shot
before my good will shatters
oh please keon has been diligently
adding up probabilities and tracking the
game and he forgot which one every
single person has been stepping on first
i get the narrative fun of it but i
shall repeat oh please we're in hell
here there's no rules in hell citation
needed
the clock continuity in this episode
isn't great but this section here is
probably the most egregious at the start
of this argument it says 5 46 the show
shows them arguing in real time for
exactly one minute and four seconds and
then shows the clock at 509 having only
ticked down 37 seconds i'm not sure what
technology allows them to fast forward
through time during arguments at double
the speed but market that [ __ ] to
marriage counselors immediately the art
behind them in this room is absolutely
pornographic but it's also kind of
amazing which means they hired an artist
to come out to the hidden death game
bunker and paint the adjoining sex room
i bet that's how they even stated it on
the contract tell me everything
you know about the game i'd give all the
sins back if he started his answer right
now with well it's really one of
fincher's underrated gems
i've accepted the use of these game
pieces to track what's going on in the
game but using them to make the
shittiest instant replay ever well
that's a bridge too far
i need you to know
you've got such a tiny
buying into the line that size is all
that matters it's such a common trope
and at the end of the day it's just a
phallus see now there's a poetic ending
for those two i mean it was until you
felt the need to clumsily comment on it
another student of the bard i had no
idea actually it's not shakespeare it's
congregate william can't wave the vips
take a break from adding nothing to the
episode just to be kind of okay at bard
since there is no way these binoculars
are doing much good when they have to be
held inches from the face because of
this mask have you ever tried to use
binoculars without holding them right up
against your eyes i mean you can see a
bit but there's no way you're getting a
good look into the neighbor's bedroom
that way i mean squid gaming he can't
see the squid you can't see the squid
gaming i used to make glass for over 30
years uh of course you did the vips and
front man have a quick but boring
discussion about this guy's ability to
distinguish between the different types
of glass and conclude this is not fair
but how is bringing your own life
experiences to the game not fair duksu
brought all his experiences of being a
big dumb meanie to the game and used
that to his advantage all the time so
how's this really any different i
suppose this could be a point the show
is trying to make saying that they
aren't actually all that concerned with
the fairness of the games but the way
this show goes about conveying this
makes it seem more like the front man
doesn't even understand the concept of
fairness at least that's the only way i
can explain a stump speech in episode
five that was in the report
how did i miss that because you didn't
even know what this game was until 15
minutes ago also because you're a lazy
rich bastard who gambles on people's
lives and probably doesn't spend his
time researching every last detail of
the pawns in your game of viscera but
mostly the first thing i see he's given
up on the three button design from
earlier this season and opted for a more
intuitive touchscreen quitter okay
standing and admiring your murder
instead of getting the immediate hell
off the death trap i suppose the clock
behind them doesn't even matter anymore
but it was on for most of the game so we
must assume that it's only off now
because it's on the same switch as these
lights at the opposite end of the bridge
and this kind of shoddy craftsmanship is
the reason i have to hit all three
switches in my living room before i find
the right one sharpish explodey glass
macguffin is cliffhangering all over the
place making it nearly impossible for me
not to immediately watch the next
episode
[Music]
i
wasn't
a mistake mama surprise surprise
[ __ ] the king is back
that's amazing isn't it
maniacal
maniacal
where is it somewhere under those bushes
was the rest of ray brauer
see that
that's the price of being in here
cost me 14 in a record player i gotta
embrace the marble
hey who were walking
seriously
i find it hard to believe the host would
miss a night like tonight we didn't want
him to know that we were having a game
night you know we used to come and we
just we don't
like him anymore so
gentlemen without much further ado
i give you
[Applause]
the derrick zoolanders center for kids
who can't read good
what is this
but recall too that in the first game
most of the contestants in the back died
after running out of time so i can
clearly not choose the wine in front of
me
what pretty eyes you have
to see you with my den
take
your mask
off i'd like to take his his face off
i admire your luck
mister
it's congress william conway
tempered glass
is made at a heat over 700 degrees pound
on it with a hammer and it brings
clearer than normal glass
[Music]